rolling on and rolling off ferries
trains and cargo ships this is what our
current frictionless border looks like
enabling over half of the trade in and
out of Britain for those running these
operations now have as little as 12
months to adapt to entirely new
arrangements outside the European Union
its customs union and the single market
how exactly to make the brexit border
work is the subject of mounting
frustration on the part of those who
have operated and transited the trade
between Britain and Europe over decades
Peter McSweeney chairs the joint customs
Consultative Committee on brexit where
are we I don't think we're anywhere
we've got no practical solutions on the
table er I can see we've had endless
discussions about sort of theoretical
concepts how we're going to deal with
customs clearances and that sort of
thing but there's been no practical
measures taking place at all as to what
we're actually going to do on day one
Sky News has learned that as part of
this process the government has in fact
done something far more unusual in
secret meetings with industry of the
border coordination group requiring a
series of secretive agreements with
transport operators covering both their
trade data but also the likely
government response in a variety of
scenarios including No Deal several
sources have confirmed the existence to
Sky News of these non-disclosure
agreements raising eyebrows across
industry at a time of furious political
debates about how to prevent new brexit
trade barriers with Europe the points of
these non-disclosure agreements is a
two-way flow in information the
government needs data on the trade
carried in lorries like this that it
simply does not track by definition in
current frictionless EU arrangements but
it also needs to give the operators of
the border some idea of likely scenarios
that's what makes these NDA's highly
unusual
politicians want to know
about them it's not a normal thing to do
to have a general non-disclosure
agreement it's bonkers and they don't
see why the government shouldn't be
revealing what it knows about brexit but
also why would it want to shackle
organizations that may want to criticize
or comment on brexit by asking them to
sign a nondisclosure agreement it seems
to me it's very much flies in the face
of open government and at a time when we
should all be pulling together to make
sure that the countries is best prepared
as it can be for whatever form a brexit
happens in a year's time
it's very unhelpful these agreements are
believed to have been insisted on mainly
by customs authorities and the Treasury
and the anonymized data showing likely
delays and difficulties was presented to
a group of senior officials known as the
border planning group I don't understand
what the what the secrecy is I mean
they're there it's becoming impossible
really to get any information out of
different departments now which is
unusual they're normally pretty
forthcoming and they tell you what's
going on so I have no idea what's
causing this it's almost paranoia I
think they're just petrified that
somebody is going to release something
that the EU think are right you know now
we've now we've got you because we know
what you're trying to achieve but I mean
what we're trying to achieve is pretty
straightforward it's frictionless
borders
certainly the government argues it wants
to negotiate the maintenance of these
free-flowing economic arteries of
European trade and so doesn't wish to
give away its hand in delicate
negotiations others say the full
consequences cannot be kept secrets from
[Music]
MPs who will soon vote on brexit
outcomes faisal islam sky news